but what we're talking about today is
HTTP 3 and quick okay so it's our first
time meeting in real life
nice to meet you yes as well there's
lots to get through here uh HTTP 3 is
obviously the third version of http
but it's a lot more than just a version
number change
it entered the internet engineering task
force standard strike became a request
for comments in I think June this year
and I think it's one of the most
revolutionary things I've come across in
all my time doing networking
but also it's kind of a really
disgusting hack I want to
try and
try and explain why I think it's so
really good and exciting but also why I
think it's so awful
there's a couple of things we need to
understand to start so
um one thing we need to understand is
the network stack and as far as
Network's concerned this is real ancient
history you've got a very good video by
Richard mortier about nine years ago for
example and more does a good job of
running through the whole thing and if
you don't know what the network stack is
take a look at that but let's let's do
the basics right let's do the real
Basics so we get up to date I'm going to
skimp over a lot of details here so
please do not be offended I'm going to
miss out completely several of the
layers but the layers that are important
today
are the application layer that's where
all of our programs live when I'm
telling us here so this is the fun one
this is normally your computer game is
this is one where your web browser is
this is one of their social networks
so the application layer exists on your
end computers on the servers that's
running the software that communicates
with the network
so that's our top level and I'm going to
put into the side here the transport
layer and the job of the transport layer
it sits on the end hosts
and its job is to make sure the data you
get is good and I'm going to specify
that more precisely in a moment below
that we have the network layer and the
network layers job that gets the data to
wherever it's supposed to be if it's
supposed to be in Berlin Shanghai London
wherever the network layer's job is to
carry the data the whole distance
and
I'm not even going to talk about the
data link and the physical layer below
this is what we're interested in today
the network layer and the transport
layer
and at the network layer there's really
only one game in town
there's Internet Protocol you can have a
version four you can have a version six
and there's other little bits of things
associated with Internet Protocol
but most of the time the network layer
is about the Internet Protocol the job
of this this network layer and the
Internet Protocol
carry the data between computers the
transport layer we have two options
transmission control protocol and user
datagram protocol last time we spoke I
was talking about transmission control
protocol this sit at the end computer
and they're trying to impose some kind
of order on what the network layer sends
to us I'm going to circle the UDP in red
because it's
unreliable if data is lost it stays lost
if data is sent so fast that buffer
overflows and all the packets disappear
they stay disappeared
I'm at Circle TCP in green because TCP
does loads of things TCP
make sure you send the data at the right
rate last time we were talking about
congestion control and how TCP tries to
get the speed of sending data correct
but TCP also makes sure the packets are
re-transmitted so if a packet is lost
it's tcp's job to make sure that we get
that packet back if packets get out of
order if they overtake each other it's
tcp's job to make sure the packets are
put back into the correct order
so let's imagine TCP it's sitting there
on your laptop or on your mobile phone
it's looking at the packets it's getting
from the network layer and it's saying
is this packet cardboard is it the next
packet do I have to ask again for a
missing packet is this packet in order
and only if the packet is reliable
correct and in order is it going to be
patched up to the application
sounds great right
so TCP is the one you want
it's going to pass you the right data in
the right order with no gaps
so on top of that let's put an
application HTTP and most of the traffic
being sent these days it is HTTP HTTP
has been around a long time
starting 89 first official version 1.0 I
think in 96. we didn't get to 2.0 until
2015 and three point uh and HTTP 3 is
gin
I think it's June might be July but very
it's this year's here's the problem TCP
is really good at being a pipe for data
it sends bits bits go in one end and
they come out the other end in order
but
it's agnostic to what the application is
it doesn't care
the other problem is
it's very very hard now to change gcp
and UDP
let's have a look let's let's have
another drawing
let's try and make ourselves
a little Network so here the traditional
way of drawing the internet is a big
confusing cloud
and we'll have some routers or routers
if you're American the only these actors
being routers and
we get to the end and let's have
something representing a server here
and here
we're going to have our laptop
and we're going to have TCP here and TCP
here controlling the reliability
and everywhere else IP IP
IP
and that's the the original design
that's how it's supposed to work and the
idea was that because of this layering
let's imagine we found out that TCP
didn't quite work or we needed to modify
it we could have another one we could
put in something else we could have
Sean's TCP or Richard's TCP and it's a
different protocol but maybe we could
pop it in at the transport layer and
that'll be fine
but
there's a big problem with that now
because actually this diagram which is
what you'd show to somebody who's
learning a beginning networks course
is missing a bunch of horrible details
we need
what's called middle boxes have you come
across middle boxes no well I'm guessing
what they might be but a box in the
middle
yeah yeah we need some we need some
extra things some people want
firstly we start to run out of ipv4
addresses well or why not first but
that's one thing that happens so we need
and then there's Nas isn't it isn't that
exactly Network address translation so
we're going to pop in and that box in
probably a nap box here
you might be sitting behind multiple
layers of these I can get home I'm
behind at least two layers of that then
you might want something else so this is
going to be a data center so maybe
we're going to pop in a load balancer
here so a load balancer perhaps well
definitely we want it firewall right so
you can't go on the internet without a
firewall so let's have a firewall in
here
and probably want a firewall at the
other end as well
and maybe you've got some middle boxes
sitting here as well doing some
monitoring here's where we start to get
a problem
because all of those middle boxes are
meant to be very neutral they're meant
to be just passing on IP traffic but
they start to make assumptions
they start to say we'll be in a firewall
let's have a look at the TCP see if
there's something dodgy about the TCP
connection the nap box does okay we need
to know whether this is TCP or UDP and
suddenly you've got a problem
because if you design something
that's not TCP
it's going to break all these middle
boxes or rather it's not going to break
Little Boxes the middle box is just
going to go Ah that's garbage Sean TCP
is a definite no-go we're throwing that
bracket in the bin it's not properly
formatted TCP maybe somebody's hacking
or it's just not going to understand it
or know what to do with it so we get
the problem that we call
ossification
we are we're stuck with Frozen
um I think it comes from Bones actually
like
um
but anyway you're kind of
you can't change
any of these things you can't have a UDP
or TCP that changes anything that's
going to be sent over the network
there's these middle boxes are a problem
why
do we want to change them
well
I said TCP was good
at being a pipe for data
but
if you know what that data is
you can make some
optimizations
if you knew your data was http
there's a lot of things you can do
so let's look at one of those things
um I think I mentioned before TLS you've
got a very good video with Mike pound
explaining that so when TCP starts off
it needs to do what we call a handshake
so we need to kind of introduce
ourselves the server make sure that
we've got our connection and this is
again this is something you're teaching
every basic networking class and I'm
sure most of you know it already or many
of you do so we have a client here and
we have a server here
and so time
is coming down in this direction
and each of these lines is a single
packet being sent so the client wants to
connect to the server it's going to send
an s-y-n a sin packet the server is
going to respond with a second packet
sin back the client gives an ack and
that's the first time the client can
send data but these days we also want
security we want https it's no good
sending things in plain text so
the clients also
now going to request a security it's
going to use TLS in HD2 and ftls 1.2
it's going to send a hello the server is
going to send back
a certificate and now we've added on
exchanges of data that's very important
because a web page is a complex old
Beast there's lots of even on a fairly
basic web page you've got some HTML you
might have a little bit of JavaScript
you've got some images you've got a
style sheet that web page even even if
it's fairly simple is going to be
several files and if you're looking at a
really complex web page dozens of files
and
this client and server may be
geographically distant so each time you
do there to there you're adding a round
trip time of delay I'm sure you can see
right now looking at that but something
kind of obvious you could do so it can
combine some of those issues right
exactly is that like yeah you've thought
of it in two seconds yeah
perfect uh and that would work really
fine
except for those middle boxes
because now we've changed what
transmission control protocol is sending
on the wire and now your Fireball your
firewall middle box looks at it and it
goes what was that thing
it's trying to be a sin packet but it's
sending me some data
tight look at that seems a bit dodgy
throws it away
now you've developed a protocol
that's maybe it's going to work for 90
of the internet all right you sent to
the internet
but it's going to die for the other 10
or 20 percent
this is the ossification problem
so we can't change how TCP is working
but we can't change what's going over
the wire like that without risking
things not getting there things being
mangled and misinterpreted by these
middle boxes
now
for a long long time
getting back to this time TCP has been
the only game in town and udp's there it
does some important things but the bulk
of the work was TCP and kind of rightly
so because it's got these nice features
the reliability the congestion control
the flow control
the idea behind HTTP 3 and quick so uh q
u i c quick originally I love this
actually originally stood for
quick
UDP internet connection but eventually
the iitf standard decided it didn't
stand for anything and it's just going
to be quick so now it's quick
which definitely doesn't stand for
anything and that's going to do all this
heavy lifting that's going to sit above
UDP the horrible useless unreliable
protocol
and it's going to look at those packets
as they come in
and it's going to add some little data
into the UDP packet it's going to add
some extra data so that we can determine
is it the same connection is this an
acknowledgment has this packet been
delivered successfully is there a
missing packet here this is where
I'm torn between thinking this is a
piece of Brilliance and thinking this is
so horrible I can't count and insert
about 12 years ago I was sitting around
chatting some Network people and Nate
day we have an idea we wanted a new
protocol and we thought about this and
we sort of put the idea into the room
maybe we could run it over UDP and then
Implement all of the reliability over
that and pretty much everybody went
that's too disgusting to contemplate
but actually
if you if you shed your prejudices it
makes quite a bit of sense so now these
things here which usually live in the
operating system now if we're running
things over UDP what we're going to do
here so normally
TCP would feed straight to hdq here
we're going to put in a new a new thing
at the application we're going to put in
this quick
the UDP packet has some extra
information and quick is going to
interpret that and it's going to do
everything that TCP would do it's going
to look for
um missing packets it's going to send
acknowledgments it's going to do flow
control it's going to do congestion
control
but because this is the application
layer we're not changing anything about
UDP we've got loads of freedom to mess
about here
the other thing we can do is we can add
in that transport layer security
I have not left myself room in the
diagram
we can add in
TLS
1.3 in here as part of the quick
protocol now
we've got ourselves a new
protocol stack
and of course the middle boxes are just
think it's just a standard UDP yeah for
the middle boxers this is just UDP oh
UDP you've known it for years to be fair
actually some places I block UDP but
that's fine because you've got good old
HTTP over TCP to fall back too
so what does the stack look like now so
our network not changed really if you
want to change the network layer which
is what IPv6 is doing be prepared to
wait 20 years the transport layer so
here's our old model where we have TCP
going up to
H well going up through TLS 1.2 going to
http s
so this is the transport layer and then
this https TLS 1.2 is our application
but now we've got this new option
we've got UDP we've got quick which has
TLS 1.3 doing the certificates and
security inside it on up at the top
HTTP s
and so really
philosophically now
this whole thing here this
is our transport layer
and we can specialize this for https
we can specialize it so there's a
problem called head of line blocking I
haven't really got time to get into but
it allows us if a packet is lost if that
gets lost in TCP
just gotta wait you can't send it to the
application just gotta wait for more
packets to come in with UDP Packers you
can read them as you get them and quick
can say oh okay I've lost a packet
that's part of that image but I've got a
packet that's part of the web page I've
got a packet that's part of the
JavaScript so I can assemble all them
and that image will show up at some
point later so cured it out of line
blocking saved ourselves around trip
Times by amalgamating the TLs with the
handshake the whole thing when it works
works really quickly and
we've got ourselves this transport layer
that's specialized for a single
application
TCP was an agnostic pipe that you shove
data in one end get data out the other
end doesn't care what that data is
quick
specialized for https
really perfect for Street for sending
over web pages
oh oh my goodness it's it's it's
muddled and horrible and nobody
if you had a fresh what we call a clean
sheet design nobody would have come up
with this
so
is it beautiful is it ugly it's
efficient it works and it's going to
take over the web so
make your own judgment
get used to it yeah get used to it
absolutely get used to it see ya
how much room it's got left so now the
sender knows
if I don't want to overwhelm that
computer
I'm only going to send a fairly well
let's just write a very silly little
Python program so I can write this
function let me make a little bit of a
bigger font size for you